Let's now start talking about UML, the Unified Modeling Language.
And we are going to start by looking at UML
structural diagrams. This are the diagrams that represent static characteristics
of the system that we need to model. This is
in contrast with dynamic models which instead behaviors of the
system that we need to model. And we will also
discuss dynamic models, later on in the lesson. We're going
to discuss several kinds of diagrams, starting from the class
diagram, which is a fundamental one in UML.
The class diagram represents a static, structural view of
the system, and it describes the classes and their
structure, and the relationships among classes in the system.